oh my god I can't believe it
we're finally getting a movie starring
two legendary action superstars Jackie
Chan the star of such films as The Spy
Next Door the foreigner the medallion
and the lego ninjago movie and of course
boots what's Nega the star of killing
Gunther aftermath Terminator dark fate
and The Last Stand and I also found out
sexy British hunk
Jason Fleming who you might have seen in
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen is
in this - what is it called a lot of
things that in America it's called the
Iron Man like 42 different titles very
journey to China journey to China the
iron mask the iron mask and whatever you
want to call it it's not related to the
man in the iron mask though to avoid any
further confusion bummer what a bummer
II right gotten so many people asking us
to check this out Jackie Chan one of my
heroes growing up Jason Fleming one of
my heroes growing and yeah man
transporter 2
and of course Arnold in 500 years no one
has ever escaped you're not going
anywhere
it's so stupid
[Music]
this dude
okay Moscow what's your name trendline I
owe you my life I'm going east my way is
filled with dangers come with me
my journey follows the Silk Road the
Great Wall of China Wow look how great
these effects okay which one which
reduces everyone see I must help save
something tells me Jackie and Arnold are
barely I've been waiting for this for a
long time
hey hey he says that in Genesis or
something like they're only gonna say
once the helmet off Genghis Khan helmet
this is the easiest part
when I have the seal of the Dragon
[Music]
[Music]
I'm excited for that one scene I know I
wonder if either of those characters are
in any of the rest of the movie or both
of them showed up for one day they're
clearly only in that gun secret they
don't leave that location what's in this
trailer which now just has me going how
do they get to this sequence are either
of them featuring anywhere else like or
is this just gonna be like a random
interlude
this is not an American movie is it I
can't tell what this is this looks like
a hybrid of like a Chinese company and a
Russian it looks like a bunch of
different companies produce this movie
in different countries is a really
international picture from what I'm able
to gather it's a it's a Russian Chinese
production okay that would explain why
it looks so good every now and again you
know you'll see trailers pop up out of
Russia that have you know big scopic
action and heavy special effects and
stuff like that it looks like that
crashed into one of those like classic
Chinese fantasy epics or something this
looks like some really great cheese yeah
I feel like this would be a really fun
time I'm just excited that Arnold the
Jackie Chan are reuniting after their
astounding work and around the world in
80 days I know when it will these two
take a picture that suits both their
strings like their real strength yeah
these not they're physical comedy
historical pictures that they're doing
it doesn't look like it's categorized as
a comedy but they're definitely giving
them some of their their classic humor
what I think that's part of the trouble
with this trailer is that everything
else looks like a sweeping effexor
whether it be intense action except this
Jackie Chan Arnold scene which looks
like a slapstick comedy like out of
Shanghai nights you know something like
that this reminds me more of the kind of
films that Jackie Chan does do just for
cash grabs like the fantasy ones that
he's not truly passionate about how did
they approach Jackie Chan for today for
this
how did they get him who got who first
and then who asked him to do a favor and
be in this you know enemy had that go to
hell yeah I would love to know maybe
it's one of those producers of Kill Bill
maybe add some on each Arnold and Jackie
and leveraged him into this or something
I would imagine that Jackie Chan was
approached first then Arnold
Schwarzenegger was asked by Jackie Chan
because they are buddies he's like buds
with Stallone and Schwarzenegger not
that Bruce Willis no one's friends are
Bruce hey you know you get on that
Planet Hollywood though would I kind of
flashed to with these two fighting
there's the Hitman franchise in part
three they brought Mike Tyson in there
huh and it's like you got awesome
martial artist Donnie Yen and then you
have the brute force of Mike Tyson and
they have this like really badass fight
okay so you know it's Mike Tyson he's a
boxer so he's before six yeah it's all
kicks what's too hard side - baby
there's a brief moment in this fight
between Jackie and Arnold were I was
thinking it could be a cool fight words
like that it's not going to be though
this this feels like it could be a lot
of fun I mean that's like yeah hassle
probably give it it's gonna be really
cheesy it's gonna be really entertaining
fun the effects don't look great nor do
I think are they going for a great
effect it might be intentional for all
we know I feel like you can get away
with a certain amount of that a yes in a
very apparent fantasy realm and B yes
with the right tone if this movie isn't
trying to take itself too seriously I
think it could get by just by yeah if it
has the right amount of fun if it
embraces the cheese that is apparent the
more cartoony more fantastical effects
could blend into the tone of the movie
it's Jason Fleming like super famous in
the UK he's in Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels he's a minor role as one
of the pikeys in snatch very very minor
role I don't really know like a lot of
his work he's been in a bunch of movies
I just find it funny that like if you
think I'm a friend of producing
standpoint for international
tribution it makes sense that you're
gonna want to slap Jackie Chan or Arnold
Schwarzenegger his name on there and the
real lead of the film out of all the
male actor seems to me he's like third
bill in this trailer yeah and it makes
me wonder is he is he more famous and
known that I actually was aware of
because I felt like we might know Jason
Flemyng has been to the masses know who
Jason Fleming is huge in both Russia and
China both that's why they were like we
gotta have him not a real presence in
the UK somebody broke it - no Jason
Fleming's on a universal name you know
you're gonna get more names in this
thing I find it funny how Jackie Chan
burr years ago Jackie Chan was like you
know I want to stop doing action movies
and just dude I don't want to do
actually because it just kept doing them
this reminds me of two of his least
action E movies that bordered on action
though which are you know the Forbidden
Kingdom and around the world nadie
defended Kingdom though had one of the
best fights ever between him and gently
where he pees on his face that's not in
that fight oh sorry it's like 20 minutes
after that fiery but the actual fight
itself that had like wire effects but it
wasn't CGI effects in the fight see the
fight here looks enhanced and that's
super yeah nothing in this trailer looks
all together real in any of these yes
while it's probably gonna be amusing and
while I'll probably go on YouTube are
you guys excited for this I think we all
know where everyone stands I'd be
surprised if someone's like this is
gonna be great
what are you talking about what's your
favorite meme trailer let us know in the
comments below subscribe click Bell's I
know yeah it's time for up
Niraj Krishnan
alright Niraj look I didn't write you a
poem we're gonna do a different game for
you though what's the cut will you do
one word at a time one word story so
Niraj we're gonna give you a shout out
John I'll take one word at a time giving
you a shout out been over a decade since
I played this kid let's do it here we go
Niraj loves to kick aa lot of children
it's his favorite hobby ever and he does
post videos of it all over the Internet
we watch him kick children frequently
and share videos herself across the
social media it's my way of showing
support for Niraj because he has a
passion seriously for child kicking so
with that in mind we love youth niraj
aren't you glad so don't let him near
your kids well rehearse this next time